[Music]
and following followers news yes
submitted by Joe Malian turkey Somalia
Jamaa lien like that Joe Malian John
Malian so white wasn't nice Joe Malian
but i i prefer that though then the the
white person that tries to to Ethne fire
i hate it because my last name it's just
s alright and the people like something
right where they stay it may already
sound unsure shut the [ __ ] how do you
say l OS f p li z LOL OS blows all those
feliz don't you hate when people go las
pilas or what did I say no los realest
some Francisco when people when people
have to correct you like actually it's
it's a Los Feliz I'm actually I'm gonna
[ __ ] punch in your hey remember that
time like three downstairs
I hate being corrected the other day
it's not my friend Denis I was like I'm
out so nauseous I don't know I said like
Spicoli oh man and she goes nauseated I
go [ __ ] you
so what did that do for you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I feel better because she took
word power in high school you have a
larger vocabulary than I do you you're a
big smarter on the I do you like my
[ __ ] Lex Luthor [ __ ] yeah I pretend
to be smart be on the TV billionaire
[ __ ] you I pretend to be smart a
freelance writer
shares the results of letting his
Instagram followers dictate his life for
24 hours oh [ __ ] scary but surprising
commits suicide
the fathers can be they can be pretty
crazy they can be the way they're
detailing a writing stuff that will he
has to live that so on Instagram stories
you can go to that news stories I should
do store who do polls are kind of bad
because it makes you judge your friends
a lot harder you know I [ __ ] up and I
was like answering these polls very
honestly I didn't realize yeah you gotta
be careful like [ __ ] marry kill you
can't do that with your friends oh no we
do that kid oh [ __ ] marry kill right now
you already married I can't play that
game cuz I don't know you guys actually
I could that'd be tough yeah I'd killed
myself before I [ __ ] any of you you [ __ ]
Michael maybe I got it teared your
button gonna be painful so this guy's
name is uber uber uber he's a freelance
writer he writes articles and short
stories he contributes to Vice noisy The
Guardian shortlist magazine and a whole
bunch of those other ones so he just
writes for people not himself yeah and
so he lives in South London that's a
nice place I guess I've never been there
but like cool it's kind of a dark side
of London isn't it sorry I've no [ __ ]
clue
see that's how you do one we can't do
that by Carol I can't but we can imitate
every single Asian accent but then I
can't yeah second idea they're like what
is he doing
go I wouldn't even know where to be can
you do like a northern England or like
southern in like a difference between
the two no you know I'm better with like
impressions and things like that he do a
good southern because I grew up in the
salad gonna do New York and like
Brooklyn that kind of and we can't do
any of that [ __ ]
no I identify if I study if I say if I
thirty minutes and I got it but then
it disappears the key is do your own
voice whenever we do English so Bryn
says video English so you just do your
own voice we're out here voice is like a
surprise you start talking like this
then it's just what sounds good
but you try it but the funny thing is
when you imitate the Asian language you
have to make fun of it as hard as
possible and it's making the most real
effect and I don't want to do that yes
there'll be a very bad idea for you but
for us is different so like when
somebody like our friend Gina she's been
to me says she hears my fitna means axe
when I speak Vietnamese words I'm
actually making fun of it can I hear it
what the hell well I'll be like nice now
Mike a little bit right and that means
like Huckabee not drinking beer but I'm
actually making fun of the language but
that's how authentic I can make it your
what are you exaggerating yeah yeah so
what rating is helping you pronounce it
right yeah so what I think is an
exaggeration is actually me following
the intonation of the yeah recently I've
been trying to learn more Cantonese and
I feel like weird thing is it's a
hardest language in the world isn't it
my husband's family speaks Cantonese I
try three more and then so like there's
this one term on the phrase like that
that I'm doing the way they say they're
like moming but they're like they say
it's so like it means my grandfather if
you want to get to white people do a
horrible accent like an Asian accent
yeah I've never it wasn't making fun the
only thing we could do is my grandfather
going I tie your shoe you tie my shoe
[Laughter]
I tell you're sure you turn my shoe good
eat you are right yeah but that's the
actual word that's real that's real yeah
white people no GUI that's like a
hilarious and I bet the Asians back
there they got butthurt over that [ __ ]
yeah Mexicans had their own one the keep
back
no it'd be like how do you say a toilet
paper in Chinese and then be like keep
that keep that which means like remove
your poop in Spanish but then it sounds
it's like yourself it sounds like it I
CIA anyways back to move on here so he
decided one morning he woke up and he
decided he was gonna let his 1000
followers make his decisions for the
1,000 yeah yeah bleach my hair like why
not
today I'm not going to make any
decisions you're making them for me
let's start shall I get up and shower or
smooth and then 59% said get up and
shower
oh they got he's got very productive
fans yeah
well honestly think about if you see
snooze then he doesn't do anything that
pulls over what shall i wear and then
it's like a putin shirt so that's what
they wanted him to wear i got a mirror
yeah or pooping that Amir or poutine
Vladimir it's like a play on okay
yeah next line where do I go right to
Peckham or left to dull which in the
ended up going right that's pretty cool
I play how do I walk normal or with a
bit of a limp and a lot of course picked
a limp and this takes care of like
there's an app that takes care of your
percentages so and you can see the
percentage the instant percentage can
you show me how to do that just I don't
know how to do it either I saw other
people you click it and you just write
what you want okay well we could talk
about your sorcery later where do I eat
this wanker spot or McDonald's
what's a wanker mean does that mean dick
like a person masturbates or some [ __ ]
yeah we're just kind of like a Nimrod
like a
dumbass I think like a [ __ ] wait wait
and then do I eat it or storm out Furies
they ended up picking storming out how
does it do this well I didn't want to
show you guys all the video clips but
there are video clips of proof of him
doing it um the next is do I pay or
break the law like hurt and probably
some girl he's sending a lot oh I'm
doing a [ __ ] weird one of this then
it's like do I kill this person or do I
kill that person and then it's their
fault
cuz they chose exactly who died be a
good [ __ ] thriller movie Halloween
eeeh and it's pretty good yeah hey
copyright that [ __ ] man don't put that
in the [ __ ] video I'm making this
movie can you do a reverse class-action
lawsuit were you like class action the
class yeah you can't what is that were
those cold like cuz they killed they
made you kill them right no not you sue
the people that voted I think it's a
class-action lawsuit but isn't it the
class going against you they would be
today yeah cuz now you got us through
the class yeah so it's a reverse suit
teacher anyway too much thinking yeah I
refused to Brian with you I can't even
figure how to do this poll on my shits
let's continue yes am I going awful east
ball pit or Scientology headquarters in
town he ends up going son
Scientology headquarter Oh Scientology
is awesome isn't it
they won't even accept me either is that
do I go in and take a free personality
test they say just walk it and grab 30
pence
yes and then next he checks his junk he
said found this in my junk mail shall I
shall I tell them to meet at the
headquarters or ask for life advice they
ended up telling him to meet at the
headquarters the ends up meeting with
the guy named Asher Asher has arrived do
I go in with him or drink outside they
end up going in what is this
Scientology recruiter he was a PR person
for some beer company this is guy have a
job freelance writer okay that makes
sense I'm like he's just doing this all
day or for a very long time so is that
what was he doing anyway
very short he ended up in Brussels Wow
yeah which is Pilate down the street or
something how FAR's Brussels Brussels is
probably about two hour flight from
everything's it's two hour flight from
London isn't it so ends up meeting a guy
so he had them decide like whether to
slide to Brussels or take Brussels
sprouts and then slow hands of doing
that or the Train and then so he isn't
meeting this guy named Patrick they end
up having beers and like you just he
made a new friend should I [ __ ] him
tonight yes he should have had his fans
write the [ __ ] pool that would have
been dope what's up guys how do we do
did you like it did you hate it well
guess what there's only a like button
and if you liked it that's the way to
communicate that to us so make sure to
hit that like button and for more
episodes click right above me
[Music]